hi Joe hi so uh you know it's
interesting talking a lot about
different forms of intelligence and I in
some ways I think this is gonna be sort
of a sort of a survey of different forms
of intelligence and different
applications doing the experiment right
are we the mice but I want talk more
about that but just to sort of prove the
point and prove the sometimes unlikely
overlap between different fields you
guys actually mentioned Frank trait yes
sir I only know Frank drink because of
the Drake Equation I'll try to
characterize it really briefly in case
people in the audience don't know and
you can correct me if I'm wrong but it's
this notion that we can kind of get a
rough ballpark estimate of how much life
there might be in the universe by taking
the number of galaxies multiplied by the
sort of percentage that we think have
solar systems by the percentage that we
think might have habitable planets by
the percentage that we think might have
life and you go from a big universe to
sort of a small number of potential
planets is that does that sort of thank
you universe and so the fractions are
reasonable it's a large number of planet
it's a big number so so we so I used to
I've for many years I worked at a TV
network here in San Francisco
very different from the SETI Institute
but you would have actually been shocked
to see how many times we invoked the
Drake Equation or sort of a or a sort of
a twist on it probably a pretty naive
twist when we talked about okay so you
know if we if there are you know so many
people in the country and this many of
them perhaps know something about some
issue and then and then that percentage
has a video camera and that percentage
is going to think to upload it to our
website and that percentage will act
when we end up at actually a very small
number that we can put on TV well
actually it's not so much the Drake
Equation what you were doing is invoking
something that we usually call Fermi
questions which are questions about a
topic for which you think you have
absolutely no answer mhm no knowledge
but if you start and and the most famous
one I think is how many piano tuners are
there in Chicago how many piano tuners
are there in Chicago well it's not a
number you'd know off the top of your
head but you can start by thinking about
how many people are in Chicago
how many people are likely to have
pianos how often does a piano need
tuning etc and you can work in that way
to numbers that are you know much better
than an order of magnitude which is you
know for astronomers that's pretty good
I love that I love it I love this notion
that there are tools sort of cognitive
tools and tricks to the trade that we
can use you know anywhere from sort of a
management consulting to your work at
SETI to our work at a cable TV network
you know one of the things I was
thinking of as you were talking about
experiments with dolphins and thinking
about ways of sort of thinking about
other intelligences I can sort of a
question I'm that occurred to me is and
you might have you might have sort of
concrete examples of this or maybe more
speculative examples but how does SETI's
work how could said he's worked just
thinking about other kinds of
intelligence be useful to us here on
earth with with other people G I'll pay
you later I think you know I I am the
ultimate Pollyanna perhaps but I think
SETI can change the world
and it can do so in the following way
people many people are interested in
SETI many people don't know don't yet
know about SETI because we have not yet
told our story well enough but if we can
get the world actively involved in the
search and after all if there's any
problem which is global this is
certainly one the environment is another
but there aren't any signals being sent
to California they're being sent to the
planet Earth
so if we can get people actively
involved so they think about it they
actually think about their connection to
the cosmos the fact that the iron in the
hemoglobin in their blood was cooked up
in a massive star eight billion years
ago you know they are intimately
connected with the universe and SETI and
thinking about someone else out
to me what it does is it's an
opportunity to hold up a mirror to all
of us on this planet in a way that makes
us see ourselves as all the same all
Earthlings right and maybe it can
trivialize the differences among humans
that we're willing to spill blood over
so I think SETI can help to change the
world I like that a lot because it sort
of puts light of this notion and we were
hearing this a bit before I've sort of
science as you know cold and rational
you're really talking about science is
an engine for empathy absolutely maybe
science is an engine for exploration
mm-hmm and I think that's well as I said
it's a lot of fun but it can actually
make a difference
we know the world's interested in said
he said he at home it's fantastic
experiment and distributed computing
well and and you talk about I don't know
if you guys thought about it this way or
not I was a study at home user I
remember running it on my old blue iMac
in my dorm room at Michigan State
University and but I mean it could have
not it could have been sort of like
piping into nowhere they could have been
it could all vanish am and it would
still would have been a incredibly
effective tool for communication because
that was always on my screen and I was
always explaining it to people and they
were going after a while it was too
passive I think you think you were
paying for the electrons out of the wall
right you we weren't getting your thing
cons we weren't so steady at home yes
you can turn the crank and you can do
service computing and it's fabulous and
it's launched this whole suite of new
scientific explorations that can be done
by people at home but I want to take
that another step farther I want to get
you involved so I can tell you the SETI
story well that's so that I can help to
trivialize the differences among humans
so that's that's really interesting
because and I want you to make the
search better because you're cleverer
than I am different forms of
intelligence very different forms of
intelligence so that's interesting so
you actually think for is for a
successful and kind of as much of a
signature
you know project as it was you think it
has it it was it's still great no it's
great but it goes only so far and and it
doesn't give you the opportunity to make
the search better okay so that's what
that's it you can just do the search the
way you can do it but I want to let you
the collective you tell me how to make
the search better not only tell me but
help me to do it um what's your favorite
movie starts with a see really um I was
I was hoping you'd be you know Last
Tango in Paris or something sort of a
curveball if you if said he had if said
he had a production company and you were
in charge of financing new movies new
stories maybe an HBO miniseries or
something to tell the story that you
want to tell what would it be about well
I'd start with contact to Zemeckis
changed the ending of the book in order
to facilitate a sequel but in terms of
Hollywood speak didn't contact one
didn't make enough money to go for the
sequel I think that's a shame I think we
have an opportunity there and then I I
don't know what else I would do in terms
of the movie world what about what about
us Eddie let's let's actually change it
up and let's do one of those sort of
great office sitcoms if there's an
office sitcom set at SETI this is this
is actually question I have because
because in the world in let me let me
back up one step in the world were the
media and journalism sometimes it I
honestly look around sometimes when I
think about the work that you guys do
it's Eddie or the work that people do
the work that Saul Griffith does and
some of these big problems and I think
man we're wasting our time what are we
doing with all this small stuff but I
will say one very satisfying thing about
it there's something to do every day
there's something to achieve every day
you know you sort of put new things out
there and you have that very fast very
quick feedback loop so an organizational
level I mean forget the sort of big
overarching mission just day to day at
the office working on these big like
could it be any bigger projects that
take many many years to play out
what do you do every day well what do we
do every day we make better code right
we make the hardware run better we've
gone through decades of building our own
special-purpose signal processing
hardware and then traveling the globe to
various telescopes to use it so what if
what are we doing now well first of all
we built our own telescope or we start
it right we have Allen telescope array
that Paul Allen funded the technology
development first phase of the
construction so we have 42 anybody guess
why 42 telescopes we'd like to grow it
to 350 break that down break that's to
be able to get on the Air day and night
when we're talking about that telescope
project is it I mean is it when you
break a telescope project down because I
really have no idea it's such an
abstraction to me the idea of complete
abstraction
they have building a telescope what it's
just a series of like meetings like
outlook invitations and you kind of go
to them and agree on things how does
like what is how do you do that oh well
our partner is UC Berkeley so you might
imagine that it's all flat demographic
so we have this users list and every
problem gets put on there and gets
commented on by everyone and then we've
got a project engineer who actually at
the end of the day gets something built
get something done we had the luxury of
having a couple of years to do
technology development just do that you
need a feed you need a receiver you need
an antenna shape you need a backbone of
computing you need code that actually
moves the telescope and then you need
the backend stuff that finds the signals
and that's what we've been doing for
years but all of these pieces people
went off into their labs and they they
they had fun they played they came up
with lots of innovations there are 12
patents that we have so far on building
this thing and now we have the telescope
and we have to use it so day to day oh
why didn't that script run last right
why didn't you know why didn't I
why did the telescopes the three
telescopes that can possibly collide why
did they shut down well because they
almost collided so what's going on
that kind of thing and and if you came
to a weekly meeting you would see that
the people who work with me figured they
have more than enough to do right on a
given day and they wished that I'd stop
having new ideas Oh who's gonna do that
right at their office politics that's
Eddie oh there's office politics in the
world right we're people we're people
and I have people who worked at Teddy
for a very long time they're very loyal
I'm very loyal to them but yeah
sometimes the mice want to run the farm
sometimes I want to say no we're going
in this direction so we actually have an
epiphany
happening at the SETI Institute we have
done our research in a stovepipe we've
done it in isolation we had our own
special purpose hardware that we had
built so really nobody else could help
but now we're just throwing that out the
door because servers are fast enough
commoditization of the search that
exponential you know thank you
Sarah Moore or Lord Moore or God or
whatever it's great and so it's now
software only so we can invite the world
in but that's a very uncomfortable place
sure when you've been doing it all
yourself so learning adopting a new
culture to work in the open world you
know leaving the Cathedral joining the
bazaar not getting mugged and really
enjoying it that could be great someone
needs to write that essay mugged in the
bazaar good yeah why you read some of
the emails I get right
what um you said you use the word
vocation earlier which is one of my
favorite word's
because it just I feel like we probably
don't use it enough these days actually
um was this kind of work you know when
you think about your career and your
your path towards this kind of work was
it like a piece of iron from a far-off
star being driven towards a magnet or
was it much more sort of meandering and
now find yourself here i got an
undergraduate degree in engineering
physics then did a PhD in theoretical
astrophysics wondering how
little stars that are too small I named
them brown dwarfs what I used Lawrence
Livermore bomb codes to model these
stars it was really a lot of fun wait
wait
bomb code oh you mean this is our the
simulations for the explosions of
nuclear bombs and you yeah nuclear
synthesis greatest are dozens what a
bomb does so I was I was having a great
time with brown dwarfs I had a postdoc
to work on that I wondered why the
public should pay me to have such a good
time but then just as I was leaving
Berkeley about to take up my postdoc
somebody gave me the Cyclops report
which was a NASA Ames Research Center
and Stanford summer study on how to
build a detector for extraterrestrial
intelligence I never thought about it
and they gave me this book because my
first year of graduate student student
many many years before I learned how to
program the world's first computer mini
computer anybody here remember the PDP
8's it was amazing we had something on
our desk that was a computer had 64 K of
RAM but heck it was on our desk so I
learned how to program that and years
later as I was leaving graduate school
that was given as surplus equipment to a
Berkeley professor an x-ray astronomer
had a really clever idea about how to
piggyback on our radio astronomy
colleagues observations and somebody
gave him this computer what do I do with
this well Jill used to so they came to
me and asked me to join their group
because I could program this if you can
code I could code and but what I got out
of the Cyclops report was not how to
build radio telescopes and blah blah
blah I got out of the this report that
after millennia of humans asking the
priests and the philosophers what should
we believe about life out there we
suddenly had some tools as a result of
world war ii and radio astronomy that we
could actually do a science
exploration belief could be thrown out
the door it wasn't relevant we could
explore and try and find out what is
that's what got me hooked on teddy
that's what I have stayed hooked on
that's why it's so enjoyable mm-hmm
do you think that um the just this
notion that code and the ability to sort
of speak this language was it was a
doorway for you and certain your entree
into this do you um how important do you
think that is across the board I mean
certainly for scientists and engineers
increasingly for journalists it's
important but would you make code like a
fundamental literacy or say everybody in
school or do you think that's going a
bit too far I worry about if we if we
don't do that
we're also dependent on somebody else's
coding I think that we actually it would
serve us all well to know a bit about
the fundamentals of what makes the
things that we rely on work how does the
world work the world works on code and
we should in fact understand a bit of it
mm-hmm a little bit I always wish that
instead of learning trigonometry as
triangles I would have learned it as
video games cuz if you look at the code
for Super Mario Brothers or you know
whatever then us sort of like pointing
shooting killing video game is it's just
like trigonometry it's just tons and
millions of little you know bits of
trigonometry every second exactly I feel
like it's a high school I would have
been a lot more interested in that than
I was in I think there are a lot of high
school kids that are more interested in
that than than what's going on in their
classroom because suddenly they can make
that connection yeah yeah interesting
one of the things that scientists I
really preachy about science and
scientists is the language as a writer I
always just like the fact that you have
things like the Cyclops report and brown
dwarfs and quirks there's that you know
you do it to just pull your yeah no you
I you know I said there's a few times
about this sort of the fun of it that
the sheer fun event I think there's a
lot of people who really love their work
and believe in it but they might not
actually use the word fun or they would
only use it in sort of very specific
sort of parts the process and the rest
they say well it's a slog I think
politics I think of public policy I know
it's in people who are
true believers and truly believe in what
they're doing and they do a good job but
they don't call it fun how important is
that oh I need science it's a slog to
you don't get any answers without really
working at it and you got all of the
politics and all the nasty stuff that
you have and any other realm of life but
it is overall fun because you get to set
the rules and so people might say they
were passionate they were compelled they
were inspired but at the end of the day
I had to say figuring out puzzles is fun
like a game like a crossword like Sudoku
really like a great game of the universe
giant giant giant sodoku because you did
good ever so you know one thing that I
wish the converse if you can continue
the conversation salt I think said that
some of his wife's family are
evolutionary
you know they believe they don't believe
in evolution how do we move forward in a
world of science and technology with
that increasing it seems to me
increasing percent of our population
that doesn't get something that's so
fundamental where everyone everyone
doesn't sort of believe the same story
or they don't they don't
I sort of believe and it's a story
that's presented at the molecular level
all right we'll keep it going
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you